Speaker 1: William Barr now says there
is a basis to indict Donald Trump,
but maybe I'll still vote for him in 2024.
This is really beyond belief and it's
it's not beyond belief in the sense that these
Republicans, former Trump associates and staffers
who we say, hey, you know what, he or she, they
saw the light. Eventually, John Bolton eventually
came out and said, Trump's incompetent
and dangerous, whoever the case may be,
at the end of the day, they are still part of the.
No matter how bad Trump is, I'm not voting for a
Democrat. So let's go through this. This is truly
stunning stuff. This was an interview on PBS,
PBS where Bill Barr was interviewed by Margaret
Hoover. And he believes, first and foremost,
that the Department of Justice at this point
almost certainly has a legitimate legal basis for
indicting Donald Trump. First clip. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: In September, you said the Justice
Department was getting close. You said, quote,
getting close to having enough evidence to indict
Trump in the classified documents investigation.
But you also said you hope they don't
indict him. In your view, is there ever a
circumstance where you think is it appropriate
to indict a former president? Oh, yes. You
know, if a former president commits a crime,
you know, especially a serious crime, they should
be indicted for it. If the Department of Justice
can show that these were indeed very sensitive
documents, which I think they probably were,
and also show that the president consciously
was involved in misleading the department,
deceiving the government and playing games after
he had received the subpoena for the documents.
That's those are serious, serious, serious.
That's a serious thing. I said I personally
think that they probably have the basis for
legitimately indicting the press. I don't know.
I'm speculating. But but given what's gone
on, I think they probably have the evidence
that would check the box. They have the case.
Speaker 1: That's pretty clear. That's a former
attorney general saying they probably have the
evidence to legitimately indict my former boss,
the former president. So certainly William
Barr would not consider voting in 2024 for a
guy who's so mismanaged and mishandled at least
some aspects of his job that his behavior was
worthy of an indictment. Right. I mean, William
Barr is a man of the law and of law and order,
former attorney general lawyer. He would not say
and by the way, I'm going to vote to reelect that
guy who I think we can legitimately indict.
Speaker 3: Well.
Speaker 1: He might he might vote for him.
Speaker 3: If Donald Trump is the nominee for
the Republican Party again, would you support him?
Well, I'm just hoping that never comes to that,
because I think it would be a tragedy if he's
our nominee, if he's the Republican nominee,
could you vote against him? Could you vote not
for the Republican if Donald Trump were the
Republican nominee? Again, I think it gets down
to what I said, which is I would have to make a
judgment at that point the impact on the country.
And I'll have to see what's going on in the world,
what who the Democratic nominee is. If
it's a progressive Democratic nominee,
I can't imagine voting for right.
Speaker 1: Between a criminal president
and a progressive. I'm not voting for the
progressive. I'm clearly voting for the criminal.
Speaker 3: Illogically progressive versus
somebody who orchestrated an attack on
the Capitol and betrayed his oath to the
Constitution. As you said, in your words,
you still might vote for him. Uh huh, uh huh.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. My vote for sure
betrayed his oath. Sure. But at least
he doesn't want universal health care
for everybody. I mean, that's crazy.
Speaker 3: Depending on all this,
it's hard for me to project what the future
holds. The question is always a comparative one.
You have to make a choice between two people.
I don't believe in throwing my way on a third
party. You don't rule out supporting President
Trump again? No, I don't. It depends on the
circumstances. What if you pray that that doesn't
come? Yeah. I think the reason our republic is
in jeopardy is because we are not throwing up
the best and the brightest for these officers.
Speaker 1: That's for damn sure. That's for
damn sure. So a reminder. When we stumble across
so-called sensible Republicans who have figured
out the truth about Trump and bah bah bah bah bah.
At the end of the day, it's about
self-preservation. It's about what's
good for me now. I think there are some
exceptions. When I look at Mitt Romney.
I'm not a fan of Romney, but he did have this
brief moment where it seemed like he was sort
of auditioning to be secretary of state. He went
and had turtle soup and frogs legs or whatever it
was with Trump before Trump was inaugurated. And
it didn't work out that way. And maybe it would
have gone differently and I'd feel differently.
But Mitt Romney has pretty consistently stuck to
his framework for conservatism as he sees
it, and it has not really overlapped with
Trumpism. He's been clear. He marked March with
the Black Lives Matter protesters. He has been
consistently anti-Trump. He entertained it when
he met with Trump that time. It's closer to. A
type of Republican I can respect, not in terms
of agreeing with their positions, but in terms
of how they've handled all this. But the Bolton
the you know, even Liz Cheney to some degree,
I just don't know. I just don't know. I think
this is basically what we should expect from
all of them. And Barr says, listen, betraying
your country and all of that better than an
ideological progressive, which tells you a lot
of what you need to know about the MAGA crowd.